ich zeige euch heute wie ihr breakfast
Burritos macht wir starten mit dem
wichtigsten überhaupt den Bacon für die
frische Pico de Gallo einfach
feinwürfeln auf eine Tomate
etwas Koriander wir geben alles in eine
Schüssel in einer Jalapeño das gehen wir
auch noch dazu limettenzeste und der
Saft von einer Limette jetzt etwas
Olivenöl und das ganze schön
durchmischen das hier ist die pure
Frische einem breakfast darf natürlich
kein Rührei fehlen
dem ordentlich Butter in die Pfanne und
schmelzen sie erstmal unsere Eier hinein
der Trick ist jetzt nicht aufzuhören
wenn wir diese cremige Konsistenz
erreicht haben ist das Ei perfekt
gekauft sieht das nicht unglaublich gut
aus jetzt brauchen wir unsere Tortilla
Tortilla warm machen zusammenbauen
und das darf auf gar keinen Fall fehlen
dahin einmal ein Herz packen Seiten
reinstecken